[Applauso]
quanti di voi hanno desiderato almeno
una volta nella vita di avere
superpoteri e di essere dei supereroi
io credo quasi tutti
io sempre fin da quando mi ricordo
da piccola ero fissata con sailor moon e
da grande con one the woman ne ho le
prove
e ne vado molto fiera
bene ora abbiamo rotto il ghiaccio è
sicuramente ho perso ogni credibilità ai
vostri occhi mostrandovi le foto dei
miei sedici
ma
vi racconto che ultimamente ho fatto un
po di ricerche in merito al discorso del
super potere dei supereroi infatti ha
scoperto che yougov ha fatto
un'intervista agli italiani e ha chiesto
questo se potessi avere un superpotere
quale ti piacerebbe possedere sul podio
troviamo
rigenerazione teletrasporto e
invisibilità
alla seconda ma fondamentale domanda poi
capirete perché
ha chiesto se potessi cambiare un solo
aspetto che riguarda te la tua vita e
migliorarlo quale sceglieresti le
risposte sono state al primo posto
situazione economica salute e situazione
lavorativa
sicuramente penserete ma questa dove
vuole arrivare bene datemi un altra
decina di minuti abbiate pazienza e
capirete tutto
intanto vi svelo qual è il mio
superpotere preferito è sempre stata
l'invisibilità
il motivo è semplice sono nata e
cresciuta in una piccola città sono
sempre stata fuori standard perché è
troppo alta e non ho mai amato lo
sguardo indiscreto delle persone per
quanto riguarda la seconda domanda non
avrei cambiato un solo aspetto della mia
vita
fino al 7 novembre 2017
per voi sarà stata sicuramente un giorno
come un altro ma non vi preoccupate non
è stata un ipotetica fine della del
mondo data da nostradamus
mai avvenuta ma del mio mondo quello sì
del mio mondo come l'avevo visto vissuto
e concepito fino a quel momento
questa è la data in cui ho ricevuto quel
super potere
ma non è andata esattamente come
immaginavo
ebbene facciamo un salto indietro che
cosa ero riuscita a realizzare fino a
quel momento
ebbene tutto quello che una ragazza
venuta da una piccola città potesse
desiderare di realizzare nel mondo della
comunicazione della moda
i miei sogni erano stati realizzati
grazie all'impegno alla dedizione al
sacrificio
pensare che ho perso anche un'analisi
ho creato un'agenzia di comunicazione
digitale per le aziende della moda e del
lusso il mio più grande sogno
lavoravo tantissimo anche 15 ore al
giorno ma non mi pesava sapete quando la
passione diventa il tuo lavoro è
difficile
vederla come un peso
per me questa era la felicità
alzarsi ogni mattina e dire che bello
faccio il lavoro più bello del mondo
quanti di voi lo pensano davvero
io spero tutti ma non credo mi sono
sempre ritenuto estremamente fortunata
per questo ma torniamo di nuovo al 7
novembre 2017 le ansie le paure e le
preoccupazioni erano
instillate dentro di me
in realtà pensavo fossero normali
effetti collaterali del lavoro che
facevo ovviamente tutti tutte le
professioni hanno un lato oscuro
ma non mi hanno ascoltato abbastanza
e il corpo dal canto suo manifesto
inevitabilmente il proprio malessere e
tutto all'improvviso
si è auto distrutto
va beh ve lo dico senza troppi giri di
parole mi sono beccata una bella
malattia autoimmune cronica
all'intestino sì ma
niente di serio
ed è pure psicosomatica
si chiama rettocolite ulcerosa fa parte
dei nemici le malattie infiammatorie
croniche intestinali
sicuramente conoscere quella più famosa
che il morbo di crohn
ecco all'inizio mi dicevano che ci vole
crohn poi diventata quelli dolce rosa
poi diventata retto quelli del cielo
insomma ancora non ho capito che cosa
c'è esattamente
faccio fatica
le malattie croniche intestinali hanno
dei sintomi molto molto pesanti
si va dalle scariche ematiche al vomito
la diarrea la febbre alta e una grossa
perdita di peso insomma chi più ne ha
più ne metta
il dolore cronico è tale da disabilitare
le funzioni della persona
e poi ogni tanto ti trovi in ospedale e
ti fa qualche foto perché le foto sono
importanti per ricordarti
che hai passato
voi penserete
ma perché parliamo di invisibilità
questa è una malattia definita dai più
invisibile per questo vi ho detto che
con quel super potere non è andata
esattamente come immaginavo
qualora non fosse chiaro a tutti il
significato di invisibile mi sono
appellato alla treccani
e ci tengo a farvi un esempio pratico
del significato di invisibile
vi sembra malata cioè allora partiamo
dal fatto questo mantello non è che
mi fa sembra tanto in bolla e comunque
ci andrei pure giro fuori da qua perché
non è che me ne vergognerei anzi
no effettivamente non lo sembro
siamo abituati a concepire la malattia
come manifestazione evidente corredata
ad esempio dall'uso di una sedia a
rotelle delle stampelle o di un
deambulatore
sottovalutiamo ciò che non vediamo il
malessere
gli stati d'animo negativi o comunque
quello che non si vede noi lo
allontaniamo facciamo finta che non
esista non lo vogliamo proprio vedere
le malattie croniche socialmente
invisibili sono più di quanto non
pensiate ma soprattutto siamo tantissimi
io ei miei amici invisibili
a titolo esemplificativo e non esaustivo
qui ne trovate alcune ma sono certa che
ognuno di voi conosce almeno una persona
che c'era una di queste
questo per dirvi che sono estremamente
diffuse più di quanto non pensiate
ci vogliono anni per identificarle i
sintomi vanno vengono e queste sono
malattie che si trovano per esclusione
praticamente arriva il medico e ti dice
allora non c'è il tumore non c'è quello
non 5 non c'è quello e quindi che ciò è
forse adesso capiamo ecco così funziona
fino a che non trovi il medico giusto
che vede che ci credi anche tu che che
cela vuoi fare che vuoi guarire che
comunque almeno ci vuoi provare
perché da queste malattie
non si guarisce
semplicemente alcune si gestiscono e
altre invece diventano croniche
la cosa brutta di tutto questo è che
spesso ti danno del malato immaginario
e non è una cosa bella
le cure sono invasive e dolorose ha già
detto troppo prima e non continuano i
dettagli perché qua se non macello
comunque sappiate che ci ho messo un po
per digerirle
spesso ho provato a raccontare e
spiegare ad amici e parenti e anche agli
estranei cosa stessi passando ma spesso
ho trovato dei muri molto molto alti
invalicabili
la
scusate
[Applauso]
la non comprensione ma soprattutto la
mancanza di tatto è solo la ciliegina
sulla torta di una torta già ricca come
come avrete capito di ingredienti
complicati vi faccio un esempio
l'amica che ti dice fa in meditazione
vedrai che ti passa oppure quella che ti
dice come stai te lo chiede mille volte
ma tanto non ti ascolta e è solo per
mettersi a posto la coscienza
oppure quello che ti dice option amico
mio che c'è una cosa come la tua sta
benissimo stai serena andrà tutto a
posto il cameriere al ristorante che
viene fa
però signorina è lei è proprio viziata
e poi c'è quella che ti dice ma secondo
me dovresti cambia alimentazione sai che
c'è che secondo me dipende dalla dieta
che vedrai che poi guarisci ecco questo
ci tengo a sottolinearlo noi non
guardiamo noi gestiamo
queste sono solo alcune cose che io
definisco ormai violenze psicologiche
che subisco da quattro anni
anzi quattro anni tra otto giorni se
avete fatti i conti
e visto che siamo in vena di date ci
tengo a dirvi
che tra l'altro oggi è il mio compleanno
[Applauso]
allora alle donne non si vede mai l'età
però io ve lo dico lo stesso perché ne
vado orgogliosa come tutto il resto
insomma li compio 27
non è vero
è vero non è vero sono 37
[Applauso]
ma ho tutta la vita davanti no
sapete perché perché grazie ai
ricercatori la mia aspettativa di vita
potrebbe essere come la vostra
per la qualità ci stiamo lavorando anzi
ci stanno lavorando loro i ricercatori
ai quali sono immensamente grata per
tutti i progressi fatti anche loro sono
dei supereroi
ho fatto un sacco di cure prima di
approdare alla cura sperimentale non è
coraggio il mio ma è voglia di trovare
una via d'uscita
a e ci tengo a precisare
sono una loro cavia
ma sto bene state tranquilli non mi
vedrete schiatta da un momento all'altro
sul palco stare sereni tutto a posto
mi sono detta la comprensione non è per
tutti
non sono io ad essere sbagliata
quindi
o semplicemente riorganizzando la mia
vita
e ho trasformato le criticità in
opportunità
e la mia malattia e non superpotere
proprio per questo ci tengo a
condividere con voi una frase di store
winston churchill che rappresenta
esattamente lame prima del 7 novembre
2017 lame dopo vela resto
a mio modo ovviamente non è la fine
non è neanche il principio della fine ma
è forse la fine del principio
sì perché che sia chiaro per me era solo
la fine del principio perché non di
certo la fine della mia vita
cosa non avevo capito fino a quel
momento
che bisognava separare il lavoro
d'arresto non prenderla sul personale ma
soprattutto trovare serenità sapete il
lavoro non è tutto ma è parte di tutto
non è il lavoro che fai che ti qualifica
ma la persona che sei e come quel lavoro
lo fai
ma soprattutto l'equilibrio che riesce a
trovare
quindi che cosa ho fatto ho lasciato il
lavoro che non mi rendeva più felice
anche lippi che andava bene bastava che
mi rendesse felice
ho eliminato le cattive abitudini e
insieme alle cattive abitudini o
eliminato le cattive persone perché
quelle sono peggio di tutte
ho dato un nome al mio problema
se proprio ci devo convivere è giusto
chiamarlo con qualche nome il primo nome
che mi è venuto in mente a rosetta
vorrei boh forse ho pensato alla stele
di rosetta non lo so però mi è venuto in
mente rosetta lo so è un po così però mi
piace mi ricorda che diciamo che vi fa
di staccare dal problema lo 0 0 9 che ha
un qualunque numero di qualsiasi
televoto di un qualsiasi programma
televisivo per me è diventato il codice
dell'estensione per gli esami del sangue
e gli esami diagnostici insomma
io amo xfactor e miss italia pensate voi
di combattere ste cose poi
ragazzo smesso di avere paura degli
ospedali e ho cominciato a collezionare
i braccetti dell'ospedale
è vero è sui miei c'è scritto descritte
anche la data quindi potete controllare
non ho barato
lo so è un po macabra come cosa ma mi
ricorda quanto io sia forte
ho imparato ad aiutare le persone che
erano più difficoltà di me lei e george
a
ho conosciuto la mamma quando ero in
fila in ospedale e mi ha chiesto di fare
amicizia con la figlia perché doveva
fare delle cure
difficoltose
da quel momento non ci siamo più
lasciati ci siamo dati una grande mano a
vicenda tra l'altro e 12 anni più
giovane di me se vede no
ho affrontato gli infiniti effetti
collaterali
dagli improvvisi eritemi alle gambe i
dolori alle ginocchia all'inizio
dell'osteoporosi
sono stato a tre mesi o delle micro
fratture al bacino
non riuscivo a camminare
ma tutti i giorni mi allenavo e mi
alzavo dando il massimo e massimo che
potevo
per noi invisibili il coraggio e motore
della vita perché alzarsi ogni giorno
con un dolore diverso è qualcosa di
indescrivibile
ho capito che bisogna bisogna essere
gentili con le persone perché non sai
mai quello che stanno alle guerre e le
battaglie che stanno affrontando
ci sono
diciamo che siamo abituati troppo a
giudicare gli altri
ma si nascondono incredibili supereroi
dietro video apparentemente normali
altrettante persone fragili
ho imparato a chiedere aiuto
anche se supereranno lo fanno mai
tornando alla seconda ma fondamentale
domanda se potessi cambiare un solo
aspetto che riguarda me la mia vita oggi
e migliorarlo quale sceglierei oggi
scelgo la salute ma soprattutto quella
emotiva che ha generato il mio problema
su cui c'è poca conoscenza e poca
consapevolezza
perciò ho capito che la
sensibilizzazione era l'unica strada noi
tendiamo ad allontanare tutto ciò che
non conosciamo
e quindi bisogna diffondere
definire parlarne
per tutti quelli che mi hanno ascoltato
che non sapevano spero di aver fatto un
regalo la consapevolezza
a tutti quelli che si trovano nella mia
stessa situazione e pensano di non
farcela
vi chiedo di essere forti e coraggiosi
perché se ce l'ho fatta io ce la fate
anche voi
bisogna avere fiducia che le cose brutte
che ci sono successe possano avere dei
risvolti positivi
perché
a voi oggi chiedo di essere forti e
coraggiosi
perché da un grande potere derivano
grandi responsabilità
verso noi stessi e verso gli altri
grazie
[Applauso]